a pair of vacant lots raising concerns
for neighbors near downtown the land in
question is right near where the
heartland mansion once stood the city
council is set to talk about future
plans later this week madison kimbrough
hears from those who are living nearby
tonight she's live with what they want
to see
[Music]
yeah it was mixed reaction when the
heartland mansion was demolished on this
lot that you see right behind me that
happened about last month but with that
comes questions on what will be put in
place along with other vacant lots like
the one that you see right here
how much traffic how much
auto traffic and how much pedestrian
traffic
it brings to
an area like this which is historic and
so
the council will listen to the neighbors
about this bob coffin former ward 3
councilman and current resident of the
historic john s park neighborhood says
he and his neighbors are ready to see
something flourish on park paseo as two
lots are now vacant for opportunity but
the concerns about how these parcels
will be kept safe and secure depending
on what goes on them is on the minds of
many this construction on las vegas
boulevard a lot of people started using
sticks to go through and
there's just there's always going to be
that element of being right in the
middle of the city i think we'd be open
to retail to commercial to more housing
i mean really anything that can bring
some good investment down here the city
planning on discussing the future of at
least one of these lots at wednesday's
city council meeting and as of now it's
looking like development is underway
with the property owner councilwoman
olivia diaz of ward 3 explains i sat and
i talked to her and to her development
team they're wanting to bring
the building back that used to sit on
that corner and maybe offer three small
business owners the opportunity to run
something out of them so there is no
drive through component at this time as
for the lot that housed the heartland
mansion the city is in a holding stage
until the property owner submits an
application for what she plans to
develop next
and we reached out to the owner of these
three plots of land that also includes
the adult superstore that's right off of
the boulevard we have yet to hear back
reporting live madison kimbrough live
local now